i am so excited to speak with our next
guest um she is a golden globe and emmy
nominated actress you know her from
projects like the kissing booth uh
ramona and beezus so a film i've seen
500 times with my daughters and the act
which is also just one of my favorite
performances on behalf of her and
patricia arquette and now she's taking
on this supernatural love story in her
latest film the in-between
it's everything take a look
i know you hate compliments but this
work is incredible
i'm serious it's like you can see things
that nobody else can that just shows how
much you know about photography
i mean i think you could sell this stuff
maybe on etsy
there is something that's missing
from like all of your photos yeah i know
this color no you
[Applause]
please welcome joey
king waiting waiting waiting
thank you for having me oh my gosh i've
been waiting for this i feel like i have
so much to talk with you about i'm such
an uber fan of yours oh i'm not gonna
stop it okay i will not i have spilkus
it's going to come out
first of all i loved the act so much you
are so incredible thank you in that role
what an opportunity and boy did you run
with it thank you it was it wasn't a
truly amazing experience as as well
which i think was the icing on the cake
for me
i and patricia arquette and you got
really close yeah she's
she's such a special woman i had so much
fun with her which is kind of bizarre
because we had to go to such dark
mindsets and dark places together but we
had a very joyous shoot which was just
kind of weird but she became we became
so close i love her you and i have
something in common which is we both
started out uber young
and um
my daughters and i have seen ramona and
visas easily a hundred times oh my god
um i love it so much and was it that
film that like hooked you
so i mean yeah i've been doing this
since i was four you know and it's just
kind of crazy when you think about it
when you're young like that you're like
this is so fun i'm enjoying myself but
you still kind of don't get the
responsibility of what this job really
is and then ramon and visas came along
and i was the lead of a movie at nine
years old and it was such like a heavy
weight on my shoulders but in a way
where i like
really loved it and i loved that
responsibility and i think that's the
moment when i really fell in love with
like the job itself and like that
feeling has lasted me to now which is
pretty amazing
was your first job like where you had
you got like thrown into water or
something my first job was a life serial
commercial and then
my fr you know what's fun my first like
movie movie was a movie called reign
over me with adam sandler and i played
his daughter in a flashback i was on
camera for like maybe 15 seconds but it
was such an amazing moment because i got
to like see him
a couple of years ago like doing the
whole the act award circuit which was
amazing
[Music]
you